from timcast.com cocaine found in the
White House prompts evacuation if it's
the old executive office building it's
likely staffed tweeted Ari Fleischer if
it's the Mansion it's likely Hunter it's
amazing the White House was evacuated
around 8 45 pm on July 3rd after the
substance was discovered by members of
the secret service uniform division
during a routine patrol of the building
the item was sent for further evaluation
and an investigation into the cause and
manner of how it entered the White
House's pending the Secret Service said
in a subsequent statement per NPR the
agency will review surveillance footage
and visitor logs as part of its
investigation the location of where the
cocaine was discovered has become a
point of controversy and as your reports
claimed the drugs were discovered in the
ground floor library of the presidential
residence The Washington Post quoted a
dispatch from DC's Department of
hazardous materials team in which a
firefighter stated we have a yellow bar
saying cocaine hydrochloride yeah I saw
this story over the weekend it was like
Hazmat situation and uh remember we were
talking to but they're like oh that
sounds like something's actually
happening turns out it was cocaine and
now they're saying it was in The West
Wing so it's kind of like either way no
matter where it was look the highest
probability is Hunter Biden hands down
no question and they've said cocaine but
I'm wondering could it have been crack
or something you know the timcast
article from Hannah Claire mentions his
uh crack cocaine addiction
we have an update on the story Biden
laughs off White House cocaine Scandal
and refuses to answer reporters
questions while press secretary Karine
Jean-Pierre suggests drugs found in
Westing belong to a visitor
I'm sure they did
this is the first time someone's claimed
to have done drugs in the white house I
think Willie Nelson and Snoop Dogg
claimed they did I was talking about
this earlier and I was thinking about it
and I could be wrong but my view of this
whole thing is the founding fathers
probably did a ton of drugs in the white
house then there was probably a period
from like the early 1900s to like the
70s where there were no drugs in the
white house and then you started getting
probably a lot more drugs in the white
house after that I think or John Kennedy
I think Mike I bet he partied hard he
would have like well yeah that's true
and she was she like she did a ton of
drugs you know I I don't know because I
actually had a good friend of mine who
worked with me on the Trump campaign in
16 she worked very very hard and because
of that she earned a White House job
under President Trump however she tested
positive for smoking weed and that was
yanked no way not getting in here so the
the stand I don't know what the
standards are for this white house but I
know historically that has not been
tolerated and there's dude
if someone came to me and said Bill
Clinton did not do drugs in the white
house I would bust out laughing
I'm sorry it I I imagine I guess back
then I imagine the president yeah but
what to your point like if you're going
to be in the Oval Office and stuff like
that even if you're some kind of Clerk
or something like that you have you have
to have some kind of clearance and if
you have any kind of drug history or if
you lie on the polygraph test then you
can't get a clearance so it makes sense
that there would be you know issues with
like your average person if you're
someone higher up like if you're a chief
of staff or if you're pre the president
or if you're you know someone like that
I imagine you could probably get the
Secret Service to overlook or ignore or
something like that but if it's just
your average
like one of the lower tier people that
actually has to work for the president
or in the office I imagine they're
getting tested and you know because they
have to have the clearance it's got to
be somebody who doesn't have to go
through security yeah or someone that
has enough clout where if they go
through security security can't be like
yo you know weird yeah because not only
would I don't look you could Secret
Service Overlook it they might also
cover it up no be like hey terrorism
everyone look out we gotta mask up this
could be dangerous like uh really it's
cocaine nobody
who has to go through security is
bringing cocaine to the White House
I I just
and what what level of staff member has
to go through security and would be like
I've got clout and I have to go to
security and they're going to find out I
have this but they can't do anything no
way I bet there's a lot more than we
realize just no it's just that they're
like addicted and they're like I'm not
doing another day without it kind of
mentality like how to surveillance
not catch it because you know they the
Discord leaker of all those Secrets they
found him real fast but for some reason
they can't immediately figure out who
dropped it in a certain room like
there's parts of the White House that
are not monitored where the story is is
this is where tourists are allowed so
there are parts of the White House where
a tourists can go
and it's not monitored does anyone
really buy that yeah I bet I think they
they know I'm pretty confident they know
exactly whose that belongs to Good Luck
figuring out and and I'm gonna say this
they have surveillance all over that
building the idea that they don't do not
is insane we know they do they have men
on the roof when you when you when you
go and visit the White House you can see
there's guys up there okay they're
watching you and they're armed and
they've got sniper rifles yes they do so
if you're gonna try and tell me they
don't have surveillance in that building
that is under so I'm going to say this
that suggests they know who did it are
covering it up therefore it was Hunter
Biden I I mean I mean to say this let's
clarify I'm not saying I really believe
it was Hunter I don't know I'm just
saying
until they actually come out and say
whose it was I am just going to say it
was Hunter because you know Occam's
razor well you gotta you gotta you got a
crack addict drug addict guy with access
to the White House to the degree he will
not be stopped by security they know who
he is the president's son
as probably his
you know whether it's Hunter Biden or
somebody else what we do know for a fact
is there's two tiers of Justice just
like Hunter Biden got treated very
gently with his prosecution for his
crimes that other people are suffering
badly for losing their families in jail
for
possession of cocaine in a place like
that
anybody else even in your house in your
car you park your car next to the White
House and they find that in you in your
car you are you're in a world of pain
but the White House one of the protected
people two-tier Justice we're just gonna
laugh it off yep
Jack besobic said he thought there's
actually a three-tier justices and
there's a little bit of an aside but
that there's the protected class there's
the plebes the regular people like all
everyone else you know and then there's
the persecuted class which is like a
unique class like Julian Assange or at
the moment Donald Trump or j6ers exactly
uh I guess so yeah where it's like it
doesn't really matter what you've done
they wanna this just it's personal kind
of he's a class of people there's the
persecuted the protected and then the we
don't care that we don't care people can
get scooped up and pushed around
sometimes and sometimes they get ignored
there might be someone who committed a
crime and they're like no I don't know
about this whatever then you have the
protected the political Elites and their
cronies and their followers and
worshipers and then you of course have
the persecuted the people like J like
the the woman in Alaska's home was rated
because she looked like a woman who went
in the Capitol building
that's crazy you know I actually went to
the DC Gulag I was allowed in to visit a
prisoner and just the fact just going in
was completely dehumanized if you ever
want to come in I can get you in too but
I went there to meet a guy named William
kressman this is the exact this is a
great example of what Jack was talking
about this guy has not been charged with
any violence he's a military veteran
he's not been charged with conspiracy
you're organizing anything it's just a
guy who showed up he was arrested in
January of 2021
he still doesn't have a trial date wow
and they have denied him his psychiatric
medicine
they have trash he tries to keep
journals and they just come through and
throw all his papers away uh he's not
been given he has two daughters that he
had not seen for all for those two years
plus two young daughters and he was
finally going to get to see them the
week after I was in to visit him and
that is just whatever the wildest thing
in the world he wanted to accuse him of
that they might even charge him with he
would have already had time serve but
they're keeping him in there in dire
conditions still not a trial date
military veteran not charged with any
violence
because they can because because not of
what he did but because of what he
believed and that's a great example of
what Jack wasovik's talking about is
this the indefinite detention because of
the clause and like what the ndaa I
think no it's worse this is unjustified
constitutional violations
speedy trial man it's right it's right
there so I mean where are we at is
someone going to file a lawsuit or
something to get some movement on this
you know he's been doing his best his
lawyer's been doing his best but they
just keep blowing not like I said not
even a trial date not even bail he has
he's a clean record he's a military
veteran he fought for this country
overseas and you know the only thing
that I've been look I've been doing a
lot of things on this field the last
thing we have decided is that the only
person who's really going to be able to
make an effect on this is the next
president so we've launched a project
called the j6 question we're paying a
thousand dollars to anybody who'll ask
one of our presidential candidates what
they're going to do for the j6 prisoners
and I'm very happy to say that today we
actually cut our first check for a
thousand dollars we announced the
project two weeks ago somebody asked
Asia Hutchinson got it on video we've
been presenting it so the only way the
only person can really fix this is the
next president so we're going to get
them on the record now so voters can be
informed going to The Ballot Box in
terms of how these people are going to
handle what I believe is the greatest
civil rights violation of our day
how many people are in prison right now
from January 6. uh we've got 141 in fact
there were 42 people just rested last
month and the doj has plans for another
thousand to be arrested there are a lot
of them that are still in jail without a
trial date without any opportunity for
bail and they're just hanging out there
how many people have been let go or have
been released uh quite a few quite a few
hundred the thing is and this is the
most disgusting part of it to me is that
the department of Justice's attitude is
that you might be able to beat the
charges but you can't beat the ride and
you can't afford it so a lot of people
are just taking a plea agreement to just
get out of it even though they're not
guilty and in fact I'm really kept
admire William kressman because he was
offered a plea agreement he had to do
two things he had to agree to the two
lesser charges and he had to condemn
president Trump why say that President
Trump was the one that made him do it I
said that's just not true and I'm not
going to admit to something that isn't
true so he has put himself through this
like a martyr and I cannot wait for the
day that he gets out and that he can
tell his story publicly because it's
that that was to ask you have to condemn
president Trump and you have to plead to
these other charges I'm not guilty of
any of it dude that's that like that
Chinese version I don't want to blame
the Chinese but that weird like
communism yeah what's that that tactic
where they make you they come in and
they make you say things that you know
aren't true to break you and then
they're like re-education kind of
mentality that's that's a I've never
heard of that in the United States
before this is the first time maybe
maybe they did to the Japanese
internment prisoners in during World War
well what they want to do is they're
using these people as Pawns in hopes
that they turn on President Trump
because if they say oh I did it because
president Trump told me that makes it
easier for them the prosecution to go
after president Trump say hey we got all
these people telling them that you can
do this because haven't people already
done that though yeah there are a
handful of people who are like oh it was
Trump's fault if but remember that's
under severe duress right because
they're getting a deal because of it a
lot of people think that Trump didn't
hasn't done enough to help those people
what could he do I don't know what do
you get that Vibe what do you think he
could do or I don't know what he's done
behind the scenes but what I do know is
the only person can really do anything
is the next president if it's the only
body the only person who's got any
ability to move this and uh look my take
on it is that they should be given
blanket pardons especially because the
vast majority of these people have not
been charged with violence you think
it's the next present so like for two
years these people are just screwed like
Biden do you think there's any like a
little a little less than two years like
a year and a half
is that we told the guy when you went in
what was the guy's name again that you
William Cressman and look I uh we have a
j6 database at look ahead America look
at america.org j6 we have the most
comprehensive database of everybody
that's been charged and it tells you
whether they're arrested or anything
like that so if you want to help William
Cressman you can look him up there and
you know send his attorneys some money
on his gifts and go
um but we have done the good thing is
the Public's now on our side because the
plurality of people agree that these
people are in fact political prisoners
but the Biden Administration does not
care and the FBI who are persecuting
these people in the doj they do not care
because there's no accountability
there's nothing you can do to stop them
other than
make an informed decision about the next
president the fear look uh you know
people people love it when I say the the
magic words Civil War
but let's think about where we're at at
the very least we it may be a Bleeding
Kansas type phase
you know before and maybe I'm wrong uh
in the 1820s there was talk of Civil War
over the issue of slavery economics and
things around this and it wasn't until
40 some odd years later that the war
actually broke out but what a point
where federal law enforcement
has
I I don't think detained is even the
right word renditioned people without
charge or trial
that's it the the Constitution is Swiss
cheese the idea that the the doj can
take people and hold them now more than
two years later
often in solitary which is torture
without charge or trial
I come on it's insane you know Iran only
held our hostages for 444 days these
people have been in over for 800 still
waiting on a trial date my guess is that
the administration feels like if they're
all let out and pardoned that Trump that
they think Trump will actually create a
revolution and they think that those
people will be the foot soldiers well
and that's like such a dumb like I think
it's just intimidating other people I
really think that the the reason that
the the people that are you know still
in prison and for the the j6 riot and
stuff is just because they want the rest
of America to be like well you know they
don't they're not gonna observe your or
or respect your rights they're going to
hold you in violation of you know the
the Fifth Amendment your your right to a
speedy trial and stuff they're gonna
they're they're just gonna
run roughshod over the Constitution if
the if the federal government feels it's
acceptable to kill a U.S citizen because
they have a suspicion that they're you
know a terrorist or because they don't
like some of the things that they were
saying then I don't think that it's it's
ridiculous to think that the government
wants to use its power to intimidate
other Americans you know yeah I fully
agree with that man it's who's gonna
they don't want anyone to Riot they
don't want anyone to even protest at the
White House I don't think they want
anyone near it I don't know about anyone
they just don't want the right to
because if it was the left they would
let it would if it was if it was antifa
they they I mean there's history there
is a there's a past history
demonstrably that they will not arrest
people on the left in the same manner
and with the same Vigor and with the
same malice that they arrest people on
the right there were people rioting in
all over uh Washington DC which is the
29th of uh May of 2000 or whatever or
2020 what was the when they I was it May
29th I think I think 29th but they're
people I I I I talk about this a lot the
reason why blackstone's formulation was
so important to the reason why we have
the right to a speedy trial innocent
until proven guilty it's the founding
fathers believed that if people could be
uh held criminally uh in in prison or
jail even if they were innocent there
would be no incentive to be a good
citizen if at any point you could be
arrested this is why it's better that 10
guilty persons Escape than one is an
innocent person suffer because if people
believe if I'm truly a good person the
system will protect me
now we can see the inversion of that
yeah that's why this is they don't care
but here's the important point
if people start to believe and
unfortunately it is true that no matter
what you do
the bite Administration the cult these
evil depraved people are going to use
the way to force against you there is no
incentive to negotiate the point is yes
this is the behavior that like any other
Domino collapse leads to governmental
collapse you can see it in all these
other countries what happens in Syria
you get protesters the the the the the
the Assad uh
regime whatever you want to call it says
we are going to stop these people
creating a backlash Occupy Wall Street
best example
about a thousand thousand people are
marching down the street Anthony bologna
the cop walks up to three random women
who were not a part of the March and
pepper sprays them because they were
yelling the video goes viral the fastest
viral video in history at that point 1.2
million views in less than a day in like
12 hours
igniting Occupy Wall Street across the
country
when law enforcement uses heavy-handed
tactics it is a spark on kindling and
what scares me about what we're seeing
with the bite Administration and the
j6ers is that it's sending a message to
people not to be scared of them but that
they are illegitimate they will not
follow the rule of law they will not
give you a fair trial therefore there is
no system by which you were involved it
is no different than a group of muggers
beating you mercilessly in the street
there's no Rhyme or Reason other than
they want to assert power over you
this is one more domino falling all over
towards a potential Civil War in this
country yeah you know this is why I use
the word dumb when I talked about these
tactics of like they're afraid these
people will become Trump's foot soldiers
if they're all LED out and pardoned the
back the problem is you're creating the
problem that you're afraid of by
incarcerating them against their without
a trial or without even a charge because
it's radicalizing them in prison and
when they come out their families will
remember and their friends will remember
and you're radicalizing an entire
population and an entire 50 years worth
of people by by violating their
constitutional rights you need to trust
the populace I maybe being in the
government is not a realm of trust you
know you're afraid and you're always on
the defensive perhaps I don't well
that's part of why I don't run history
shows that there's a silver line to this
because how many of the great leaders
who've done wonderful things for their
country at some point in their early
life were political prisoners like
Mandela or Martin Luther King or in
India veersavakar that's a pattern
throughout history of great positive
revolutionary leaders at some point
crossed a civil disobedience line across
the administration and ended up in
prison and that you can see that in
countries all over the world I don't
think we're quite at Civil War yet and
I'm gonna because here's here's the real
here's the problem as I see it as a
community organizer somebody that does
voter registration and voter turnout and
the Georgia Senate runoff
in the urban counties the progressive
Urban counties turnout was in the mid
80s
in the rural counties where I think at
least as many voters are turnout was in
the mid 50s and there you have the
outcome of the election if turnout in
those rural counties was anywhere close
to the urban areas
they those people would have a louder
voice but unfortunately they do not turn
out they are not part of the ballot
harvesting machine they're not part of
the voting culture and that's where I'm
putting my effort to try to change I'm I
wouldn't do too well in a civil war I've
got terrible Vision but in in terms of
community organizing and in elections I
think it's there if we just can if we
just have to seize it and you know our
constituency is disaffected patriotic
Americans Rural and blue-collar
backgrounds and the best example of
somebody like this from history
is Dorothy from Wizard of Oz from a poor
background probably her family didn't
own that farm uh they were at the whims
of much more powerful forces in the
economy and in the government and she
was just blown off with a tornado to
some foreign land where she had
absolutely no control and no power but
she realized by the end she had the
power all along in her ruby slippers and
she just needed to tap them together and
stay home sweet home if we can just get
our people in the same way to recognize
if they cast those ballots an informed
ballot and get engaged with the process
they can solve their problems how do you
feel about voting machines like I'm very
concerned about proprietary voting
machines where we can't see the code so
we don't know if they're flipping vote
tallies in the background how do you
foresee a solution to at least create
transparency so that we know for sure
that it's giving us accurate vote
tallies so I have documented cases where
the voting machines made a mistake and
there was a a county that where this
happened it was caught and it was fixed
but what I think is the solution long
term is to insist on open source voting
equipment you know hand count that's
technically open source and even if you
don't believe because you know all these
Democrats and leftists were saying
before 2020 that oh I see these machines
changing votes right in front of my eyes
Kamala Harris said that herself there's
a documentary on HBO now they're all
denying it but even if you don't believe
that there's a lot of good reasons to
switch to open source voting equipment
which is that it's a hell of a lot
cheaper it's like half the cost and when
you get proprietary equipment you're
locked into that company maintaining it
fixing it updating it forever and that
gets very expensive it's a monopoly
whereas if it's open source you can have
an in-state tech company you can create
in-state jobs to maintain it and update
it and I'll tell you it's really more of
a republican issue now but there was a
democrat in Congress who is a scientist
and he actually proposed a law manding
that all voting equipment be open source
so even in places like California we're
making progress on that front and I
honestly I I have not seen any evidence
of machines intentionally changing the
outcome of a result of a vote and I've
seen a lot of evidence in the contrary
but it's really about restoring Trust of
the public they need to believe it they
need to have a Matt Brainerd walk in and
see oh yes these machines are correct
the code is right it's doing what it
says it can do to restore their trust in
the voting system and I think that's why
so many on the left oppose it is because
they don't want the trust restored
because they want people discourage from
voting thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time